مسائل يدخل اليوم الخميس 2 مايو 2009 12
الحاضر حتى الحظر الامريكي التام على
صادرات النفط الايرانيه ومع هذا الحظر
التام اللي ب يهدف الى تخفيض الصادرات
الايرانيه من النفط الى زيرو فور السؤال
المهم متى ترفع ايران في الراي البيضاء
ماذا تستسلم الى هذه الضغوط العنيفه ايران
ومن ورائها حلفائها في الخليج وفي اسرائيل
هل تستطيع ان تظل تقاوم كل هذه الدول
الكبيره الحقيقه عشان نعرف الاجابه عن
السؤال ده لازم نفهم الوسيله اللي حددها
الولايات المتحده والاحداث اللي هي طلبها
في تعاملها مع ايران ولازم نعرف ايران
بتفكر الزاي ايران الولايات المتحده في
تعاملها مع ايران حددت وسيله وحدد الحدث
الوسيله هي عزله سياسيه وديبلوماسيه
وحصار عسكري من كل جانب ثم ضغوط اقتصاديه
غير مسبوقه اسفرت عنه عل اقتصاديه كبيره
الاقتصاد الايراني وفق ال صندوق النقد
الدولي سوف ينكمش كما هو متوقع في العام
الحالي بنسبه سته في المائه الاقتصادات
عليهم كثير لكن الاقتصادي مش يعني ينتج
اقل مما كان ينتج في العام الماضي والابن
دائما في خطر كبير
مؤشر اخر التضخم وصل الى حوالي اربعين في
المائه من الوظائف ان يصل الى خمسين في
المائه وعمل تعاني بشده الريال فقط حوالي
ريال الايراني فقط حوالي ستين في المائه
من كانت وقدام الدولار مظاهر معاناه
الاقتصاد الايراني لا تخفى على احد والان
امريكا تريد ان تتم هذه المعاناه بان تصدر
الاقتصاد الايراني اهم موارده وهي الصدر
الايرانيه كان عند انسحاب الولايات
المتحده من الاتفاق النووي في في يونيو
2018 اعلنت انه مهله سته شهور قدام العالم
كله قبل توقيع تجديد العقوبات على
الاقتصاد الايراني وبعدين ها تبتدي تطبقها
وبدا التطبيق في نوفمبر 2018 2018 اعطت
فقط استثناء اللي دول وبعدين النهار ده
بينتهي هذه المهله يبقى غير مسموح لاي
دوله ان تستورد قطر نفط واحده من ايران
بدايه من اليوم والا سوف تقطع هذه الدول
او سوف تعرض هذه الدوله نفسها بعقوبات
امريكيه الحياه اللي فيه مشكله في الوسيله
وفي مشكله في الهدف اللي تكلم عليه الايه
هي المشكله الوسيله ان الوسيله اللي هي ت
صفير
الصادرات الايرانيه من النفط يعني وسيله
معيبه مبنيه على افتراضات مهياش وديها
مائه في المائه الافتراض الاول
ان الدول المستثنى وهي ت من دول اللي هي
الصين والهند
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وتركيا وبعدين
عندنا الدول توقفوا بالفعل اللي هي
ايطاليا و طيوان اليونان الدول الثلاثه
الاخرين المتوقفه بالفعل من خمس دول اللي
ذكرتهم في الاول سوف يمتثل للقرار وانهم
يجدوا بديلا سهلا عن النفط الايراني الى
مساله محل شك ومن البدايه الصين قالت انه
احنا شايفين ان هذا طلب غير مشروع تستورد
حوالي نصف البترول الايراني او حوالي
اربعين في المائه من الصادرات الايرانيه
وبالتالي هو شايف ان الطلب طلب غير مشروع
تركيا شايفه ان استبدال النفط الايراني
برفض اخر مكلف ليها يكون له تبعات اخرى
تبعات سياسيه اخرى يعني لانها تعتبر ايران
دوله حليفه في كل الاحوال الواضح ان الدول
الخمسه يعني لن يكون من السهل
انهى تستغني تماما عن النفط الايراني
الامر الثاني انه عمليه الاستاذ مادي لازم
البديل البديل عارضت السعوديه والامارات
اللي هي تعود السوق العالمي عن النقص لا
يتعرض له نتيجه عدم تصدير النفط الايراني
وايضا في صعوبه ان السعوديه والامارات
تعود هذه الكميات من غير ما يتاثر سعر
النفط في السوق سعر البترول في السوق ومعي
حفصه عليها عند سعر معين لازم كميات كبيره
الكميات الكبيره يعني
تعود ال ال كل الناس اللي موجود النقص
الايراني وده ممكن لكن في مشاكل ثانيه
يعني السوق الليبي عنده مشاكل الانتاج
الفنزويلي عنده مشاكل الاثنين دول ممكن
انخفض ان تكون من البترول يكون صعب على
ايضا الامارات والسعوديه ان تعوض هذا
النقص
في سبب فني ان البترول اللي بدو ايران هو
من النفط الخام الثقيل
والبترول اللي بدو السعوديه تحديدا من
الخام الخفيف وهذا لا يحل محل ذلك
وبالتالي ايضا هناك صعوبه الامر الرابع ان
ال ايران ليست دوله قليله الحل هي دوله
اعتادت ان تتعامل مع العقوبات على مدار
ثلاثين سنه او اكثر وبالتالي هي دائما
تتجه وسيله تتحاشى هذه العقوبات اما بيع
نفطها سرا في الاسواق في السوق السوداء
اما ان هي بتقوم بتعطيل الانتاج العالمي
من اسواق اخرى بطريقه او باخرى علشان يظل
هناك حاجه الى بطولها زي اللي هي مثلا
تعمل
تنفذ تهديدها باغلاق مضيق هرمز اللي قلنا
عليه في الحلقه الماضيه صحيح صعب لكنها
يكون خيار شمشوني اذا وجدت انه فعلا الدول
الاخرى قرارات الاستغناء عن نفسها او الحل
الوصف اللي تكلمنا عنه انها تجعل المرور
المضيق حرمه الصعبه بحيث انه يقل التدفق
على الاسواق العالميه انها تستخدم
ميليشياتها في دول مختلفه علشان تعطل
المصادر انتاج البترول فيها انها تشن
هجمات الكترونيه على بعض الحقول المنتجه
للبترول خصوصا في دول الخليج طبعا اللي
تعتبر ان تعهدها بتحويل ما ينقص السوق
نتيجه عدم تصديرها للنفط التصرف او يعني
اعلان حرب عليها في كل الاحوال ال الوسيله
اللي اعتمدت او الافتراضات اللي بنت عليها
الولايات المتحده هذا الوسيله اللي هو
تصدير النفط الايراني مساله يعني معيبه
ويبدو انها يعني اه يصاب انهى تتحقق
بسهوله
تحققت ووقع عبد هذا العدد الضخم جدا على
الاقتصاد الايراني ايضا سوف يظل استجابه
ايران رغم المعاناه الشديده مساله محل
الشك ليه لانه الطلبات الى الامريكان طلب
منها من ايران يصعب جدا انه ايران او اي
دوله اخرى تقبلها مطالبين العراق
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي حده اثناشر طلب
عشر طلب يعني ممكن نتكلم عنه في حلقه اخرى
لكن طلب تقول خلاصات هكذا ال ايران تتخلى
تماما عن اي طموحات لتطوير ال ال
التكنولوجيا النوويه السلميه
قريه وانها تتخل تماما عن تطوير كل انواع
الاسلحه الباليستيه سلميه او مش
التقليديين ال قادر على حمل رؤوس تدميريه
تقليديه او طبعا رؤوس نوويه انهى تتخلى عن
اه تحترم سياده الدول اللي هي بيكونش فيها
اي تدخل خصوصا في العراق ولا في سوريا ولا
في افغانستان وانها تم سحب تماما من سوريا
وانها تتوقف عن دعم الجماعات بين قوسين
الارهابيه كما طرح الولايات المتحده حماس
وحزب الله الى اخره وان تتوقف عن دعم
الحرفيين في اليمن ايجاز ل لما تنظر الى
هذه الطلبات تجد انها طلبات تعجيزيه تماما
لا طلبات تعجيزيه الدول دائما مارس يعني
وتتحرك سياستها الخارجيه بتفرضها عده امور
اهداف الدوله بحقه قدرتها وقدرات الدول
اللي حواليها لكن لا يطلب ابدا من دوله
انهى تتخلى تماما وتنسحب الى التخلي تماما
عن سياستها الخارجيه وتنسحب الى داخل
حدودنا بمحض ارادتها يعني على سبيل المثال
ايران الولايات المتحده تطلب من ايران ان
هي ما يكونش فيها اي دور في اه العراق
ويكون بهذا الشكل انه في الولايات المتحده
تبعد حوالي عشره الاف كيلو متر عن العراق
انا اقول لكم ايران انا افكر ازاي يبقى
الولايات المتحده بتحافظ على مصالحها
امنها القومي بانها بتيجي بقوتها على
مسافه عشره كيلو عشره الاف كيلو وتضع اكثر
من خمسه الاف وخمسمائه جندي امريكي لكن لا
يسمح لي لايران ان هي اي دور يذكر في
العراق اللي بينها وبين ايران الف
وخمسمائه كيلو حدود مشتركه
يطلب من ايران انها تسمح او تشجع على نزع
الاسلحه من
الاشياء اللي هي مواليه مع العلم ان كثير
من الميليشيات دي اصبحت مليشيات قانونيه
تباركها الحكومه العراقيه هذه الميليشيات
الجزء منها هو اللي لعب اولا دور اساسي في
مواجهه دوله الخلافه الاسلاميه او داعش
العوده يقولوا انه مش الا انا بقول ان هذا
امر محمود او غير محمود هوري ان
الايرانيين من المستحيل ان يستجيبوا الى
هذا الطلب من المستحيل ان اتقبل
الايرانيون مثلا فكره انهم يتوقفوا عن
التعامل مع طالبان هم يدركون انه
الامريكان اللي قطعوا ايضا مسافه 12 الف
كيلومتر وست قرب اكثر من اطناشر الف جندي
في افغانستان اللهم اهداف احد هذه الاهداف
دي انهما يحصروها من ناحيه افغانستان فكيف
يطلب من ايران ان هي اي دور ولا اي حركه
في الدوله ذاتها اليها دوله افغانستان
عموما
حتى لو افترضنا انه هي قررت ان تتقبل كل
هذه الطلبات اللي هي تقريبا حجمها
الاستسلام الياباني للولايات المتحده في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بعد ضربها بالسلاح النووي حتى في هذه
الحاله يعني لا يوجد اي منطق يعني مثلا
الولايات المتحده تطلب من كوريا الشماليه
انها تتخلى عن السلاح النووي فقط السلاح
النووي في مقابل حزمه كبيره من الحوافز
الاقتصاديه
بيقولوا لهم انتم سوف تصبحون مثل فيتنام
دول ناميه دوله مواعيدها واقتصاد واعد
فهنا عروض
الحوافز الاقتصاديه عن خليكم على السلاح
النووي انما في حاله ايران ويطلب من
التخلي عن النووي وال تقليدي
المليشيات المختلفه والاسلحه التقليديه
وغير التقليديه بدون اي
ليس فقط لان ايران تدرك ان هي اذا هي حتى
فقط وقبلت كل هذه الطلبات وبدون مقابل لن
تكون المساله المساله لن تنتهي عند هذا
الحد والاغلب اللي هم يدركوا انه يكون
مصير ايران هو مصير ليبيا ليبيا ل ما تخلي
الرئيس السابق معمر القذافي عن برنامجها
النووي السري وسلم الغرب وكل اصرار وكل
ملفاته كفاءه الغرب بضرب ليبيا في سنه
2011 واغتيال معمر القذافي يدركوا انه مصر
هم يمكن ان يكون مثل مصير العراق في الفين
وثلاثه ومصير صدام حسين بعد ان فتح كل
منشات
للتفتيش الدولي وتاكدوا ان العراق ليس
فيها اي نوع من اسلحه الدمار الشامل في
العراق في الفين وثمانيه الفين وثلاثه وتم
تعليق صدام حسين على حبل المشنقه
ايران يجب عشان نفهم سلوكها بغض النظر عن
اي مشاعر الكراهيه ونعرف ان ال مشاعر
الكراهيه والرفض موجوده خصوصا في دول
الخليج لدى قطاعات واسعه في دول الخليج
بغض النظر عن المحبه او الكل لازم نفهم
اذا اردت ان تتعامل مع القمه يجب ان تفهم
ايران عندها مخاوف اساسيه وعندها دوافع
اساسيه لسلوكها هي دوله ب تاره نفسها انها
دوله امبراطوريه قديمه دوله مهمه في
الاقليم الان عمرها الفين وخمسمائه سنه
عدد سكانها اكثر من ثمانين مليون نسمه
وبالتالي هي ترى انه من حقها مثلا كل دول
المنطقه ان يكون لها تاثير ونفوذ وقرار في
كل ما يجري ولها
بتعتقدوا عندها مخاوف المخاوف كيف بتشوف
انه كل هذا الاهميه من وجهه نظرها على
الاقل فهي عندها عقليه الدوله الاقليه هي
دوله فارسيه في محيط عربي او لدى او حولها
جيران عرب يعني من الناحيه الشرق الامر
الثاني انها دوله شيعيه الغالبيه شيعيه في
محيط سني
وهذه المخاوف مخاوف بس نظريه هي مخاوف
مبنيه على الحاضر وعلى التاريخ الايرانيين
عندهم يتذكرون بشكل جيد
محاولات الدول الخارجيه سواء الدول الكبرى
او دول الجوار في في الحال الحق الاذى بهم
يتذكرون بشكل جيد كيف انه الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق
وبريطانيا ال قاموا باحتلال ايران اثناء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وب يتذكروا ازاي
بريطانيا والولايات المتحده بدون مبرر
قرروا المهمه يضعوا ايديهم على النفط
الايراني
وفي مقابل ذلك او في سعيهم لتحقيق ذلك
قاموا بالكلاب المدبر على حكومه منتخبه هي
حكومه محمد مصدق ثلاثه وخمسين وهو يتذكر
جيدا جدا انه سنه ثمانين تم تشجيع الرئيس
العراقي صدام حسين على بدء حربه على
العراق متمنين وانه الحرب دي انضمت الى او
دعم دعم العراق فيها ودعم صدام حسين فيها
معظم الدول العربيه وان امريكا كانت معظم
الوقت في صف العراق باستثناء مره واحده
اللي سموها ايران قادره اللي هي عده اسلحه
تكلمنا عنها كده واعتبرت فضيحه وبالتالي
هي تنكر مع حدا من استهدافها بدول الجوار
واحد الاسباب اللي بيخليها حريصه على
تطوير اسلحه اه اه بالستيه هي تجربتها
المريره من استهدافها من الصواريخ
العراقيه اللي دمرت معظم المدن الايرانيه
في الحرب اللي استمر من سنه ثمانين الى
ثمانيه وثمانين يعني ايران دوله لديها
اهداف عندها مخاوف و تعلم جيدا ان هي ان
استجابت الى كل هذه الطلبات التي لا تطلب
من دوله فلن تكون ذلك فلن يكون ذلك بدايه
للحل ولكنه بدايه لنهايه وعلى الاقل اذا
ما كان شيء معيار للدوله كامل ويكون في
شكل تغيير للنظام ماذا يحدث اذا تم تغيير
النظام وهو يبدو انه هو الهدف الاساسي من
السياسات الامريكيه السياسه الامريكيه
بتقدم طلبات غير منطقيه الهدف منها في
النهايه انه تعمل ضغوط في انهار النظام
وبالمناسبه الكلام ده مش خيا لان المستشار
الامريكي والجانب يدافع عن فكره تغيير
النظام ووزير الخارجيه الحالي بيدعوا
بيقول اذا هم لم يستجيبوا تغيير النظام هل
اذا حصل تغيير في النظام لو افترضنا الى
وهذا امر صعب جدا صعب جدا لان هم بيحاولوا
لهم حوالي اربعين سنه او على فترات طويله
خلال اربعين سنه لكن كان كان صعبه في
فنزويلا اللي بيحاولوا من سنه الفين
وثلاثه انهم يغيروا نظام معجزه ما افترض
انهم غير والنظام اذا غير النظام ممكن
رغم صعوبته من المتاعب التي تسبب بها
ايران لامريكا اسرائيل لكنه لن يغير ابدا
من اي مشاكل تتعلق لدول الخليج فيما بعد
انه سوف يظل لو افترضنا ان التاريخ عدينا
الى ما قبل ما قبل عام ثلاثه تسعه وسبعين
وقلنا نظام اقرب الى نظام الشاه ما زال
كان ايضا نظام الشاه هو لدى
نظره امبراطوريه لدولته وباعتقد انه يجب
ان يكون صاحب الكلمه الاولى في الخليج
العربي الذي يسميه الخليج الفارسي وان
يكون صاحب القول الفصل فيما يجري من اه في
دول المنطقه خصوصا في الشرق من مشاركه
الخليل يعني الدول الخليج
الحل في ايران اولا انا قلت لكم لايران
يكون
تستجيب وترفع الرايه البيضاء ايه البديل
وزاي ممكن دول الخليج تتعامل مع المخاوف
الايرانيه بطريقه افضل هذا يقتل من ناحيه
اخرى ان شاء الله اشكركم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]